that's not the case with male Comics  once they have a baby they'll get up on  stage a week afterwards and they'll be  like guys I just had this baby that  baby's a little piece of [ __ ] it's so  annoying and boring and all these other  dads in the audience are like that's  hilarious I identify and their Fame just  swells because they become this  relatable family funny man all of a  sudden  this is the best of Ali Wong right let  me check again was it the worst  no no it's the best okay all right look  well first of all I you know I have  watched a lot of male comics in my day  and many of them you know make jokes  about Parenthood fatherhood I have never  heard any of them say my baby is a  little piece of [ __ ]